deputy prime minister is here with us uh
back home uh inflation record highs
what are we going to do about it well
we've uh first of all we've got to make
sure we've got the strength and the
fundamentals of our economy which rishi
sunak is doing the investment is coming
in there are all sorts of things which
show that this economy the basics are
right
in relation to inflation itself
i think that's one of the reasons why
we've put such emphasis on restraint in
relation to the public sector pay and
some of the strike action we've seen
because we know that if public sector
pay keeps going up
then it will only keep inflation high
for longer we are facing a global
struggle against inflation if you look
at the uk figures they're broadly
comparable to the us or in europe the
dutch and the belgians and it's going to
be difficult and we really do understand
the pressure that those on low incomes
are facing at the moment they're
struggling to make ends meet that's why
there's a 15 billion pound package of
support uh rebate 400 pounds on energy
bills cutting national insurance next
month but we do need to have the kind of
pay restraint in the public sector that
we've been talking about and which is
par at the heart of the challenge with
the unions and rmt and the strikes we're
facing otherwise we'll just have the
vicious cycle of inflation staying
higher for longer so what happened to
the pm saying last
october i've got the guts to make as a
high-wage country well that's why we've
increased the national living wage so
for those
eligible workers they got a thousand
pounds more in relation to those
particularly reliant on universal credit
but are in work they'll get an extra
thousand pounds
and we want to go further and faster but
we've got an immediate global challenge
in relation to inflation very much
sparked by the combination of the
aftershocks of the pandemic as the
economies around the world have got
going again but also particularly in
relation to energy fueled by russia's
appalling invasion of ukraine and we've
got to deal with that alongside those
broader long-term initiatives a
high-wage country but um restraints on
public sector pay how does that square
because if we don't have those
restraints inflation will go higher for
longer and that will only undermine the
pay packages of workers particularly the
most vulnerable workers for a longer
period of time we are taking the action
we're taking a firm line with for
example the rmt unions precisely because
we want to protect this erosion of pay
packets by inflation and i'm afraid if
we keep seeing uh increase in those
wages it will create a vicious cycle
which will hurt them what rmt are doing
i think at one level for the unions i do
understand they feel their job is to
protect their workers and understand
that but it is totally counterproductive
if we follow for example network rail in
the negotiations uh with the unions uh
the three percent offer uh the unions
are saying it must be seven percent that
will only undermine the lowest paid uh
workers salaries for longer we've got to
understand that vicious cycle we've got
to avoid it uh grant chaps told me
yesterday that the government was
staying out of it
well i'm just explaining you to you the
position that it's absolutely right and
historically under successive
governments network rail and the other
rail employers are the ones that engage
directly um with the uh the unions but
of course the the um there's overall
ministerial accountability for the
mandate but yes in terms of the
negotiations that's right that's the
network rail to con so why doesn't given
that why doesn't the transport sector
get in the room with them and sort it
out well you know it was interesting i'm
pretty sure i heard the rmt
leader saying that he didn't want to sit
down he didn't want him
he said he didn't say it well i asked
him yesterday we we we i'm afraid i
think this is why uh this risk being
politicized actually the successive
approach of governments is to have
network rail uh dealing with the
technical aspects of that in the room
and i think that would hopefully
increase the chances of a if i can say a
de-politicized approach resolution which
we do want to see how long are you going
to let the strike go on for we can't
allow i'm afraid uh the unions in this
very militant way that they've proceeded
to win this argument because it will
only hurt the poorest in our society
that they're exercising their democratic
right to strike well i think uh look let
me tell you why i think there's been a
16 billion pound package funded by the
taxpayer the very people who are
suffering uh as a result of the this
disruption to trains that 600 pound per
household in this country and i think
the respon and that's to see the rail
industry and all those workers through
tough times during the pandemic i think
and of course after the pandemic we need
reforms because well let me explain
because of the passenger um uh uh
the people of the home the work life
balance is changing people working more
from home and also frankly there's some
practices were outdated that needed to
change and to run the the railways
efficiently that's absolutely right and
i think given that big bailout that the
taxpayer put in i think a lot of people
will feel that they are irresponsible
the the unions and rmt particularly well
actually i think uh because saying that
you can't win in this negotiation and
then disrupting
millions of people including students
who are trying to go and sit their exams
including and and by the way kay it's
always when we have these strikes
particularly when you're talking about
the trains that the the the blue collar
uh uh workers suffer the most the people
that clean uh they know that but they've
still voted to strike well the the the
rmt members have but in broader and
that's just rail workers but i'm just
saying the cleaners the electricians
those who cannot work remotely like many
white collar workers can use in teams
these are the ones that are being
disrupted the most so again i understand
why unions feel that they've got to
fight the corner of their sectors but it
is the lowest paid who suffer the most
from strike action and also if we give
in to this inflationary spiral that the
union's demands would lead to mick lynch
spoke to me yesterday and said that he
was appealing to other unions
for coordinating multi-sector strikes
for months to come it's going to be your
summer of discontent um look
we've got unemployment uh
record lows lowest levels since i was
born in 1974 and the fundamentals of the
economy are strong we do understand all
of those pressures on workers
particularly for the next year with
inflation high but if we want to get
inflation down quicker we cannot relent
and i think uh on these demands happy to
take on the unions hey on i always want
to avoid conflict if i can but i think
we've got to protect the public and the
lowest paid and that means not allowing
a vicious cycle of higher inflation for
longer that is an argument that we must
stand firm on you're responsible for
criminal barristers in your job as
justice secretary are they on 25
well i think it's um regrettable that
they voted for strike action um i mean
actually it's only 43.5 of the cba
members balloted who supported these
specific additional measures just to
give you a clear understanding we've
already committed to a 15
fee uplift 135 million pounds going in
the typical criminal barrister will see
an increase
of seven thousand pounds i'm introducing
this regulation it's a statutory
instrument next month i i don't think uh
that uh that it's the right thing to do
and i think if the cba leadership
couldn't convince over half of its
membership to take these specific
measures i don't think the public will
be coming so they're not going to get 25
no they'll get 15 percent as i've
already made clear okay and um let me
talk to you about um bill of rights uh
what's the need for this new bill of
rights that you've been rushing about in
the papers this morning when we've
already got the european convention on
human rights and the human rights act in
effect
yeah absolutely look
um we've got a proud tradition of
liberty in this country we want to
reinforce the quintessentially uk
freedoms particularly freedom of speech
which we've seen whittled away in
various ways we think that that is the
liberty that guards all the others at
the same time we've seen a lot of
elastic interpretations of human rights
particularly fueled by the human rights
act sections two and three i won't go
into all the detail and we think it's
right to uh have a proper separation of
powers uh the uk court the uk supreme
court should do what it says on the tin
and be supreme in the legal
interpretations and if the goal posts
shift and you'll remember the whole
context around prisoner voting where we
were told that we had to give prisons to
the vote i think parliament should have
the last word when it comes to the law
of the land and what our reformers will
do as i said strengthen free speech but
curb the abuses for example the ability
of serious foreign criminals convicted
of custodial offences to frustrate their
deportation on frankly pretty spurious
grounds don't european court rulings
remain binding though
well so there's three contexts one in
the context of inter case law there's no
reason why as a matter of law
international domestic we need to
follow our courts need to follow the
strasbourg case law we'll make that
clear secondly when it comes to
individual rulings of course we're
signatories of the echr we're staying in
the echr i think that's important echr
will remain incorporated well it's um we
will of course when the goalposts shift
and prison of voting is the example when
what the strasbourg court is ultimately
engaged in his judicial legislation i
think for that we're right to make clear
as we did in prisoner voting that
parliament has the last word on the law
of the land i think that's a sensible
approach
and of course the strasbourg court
particularly under robert spano its
current president has talked a lot about
the marginal appreciation for domestic
institutions the rulings remain binding
well it's a matter of international law
if you get an adverse ruling against you
um of course
they're binding but what is also allowed
within the marginal appreciation
where you feel that they they're wrong
is to push back you're we're it is a
totally legitimate thing to
to to press back uh to avail ourselves
the margin of appreciation and and
prisoner voting shows that that does not
lead has been kicked out the council
europe i remember in 2015 i went to
strasbourg everyone told me we'd get
kicked out of the council of europe if
we didn't give prisoners a vote we
didn't we're still in and we've got one
of the best records of compliance let me
ask you this then you say the bill will
boost freedom of the press
um does that chime with number 10
intervening to get a times article
removed about the prime minister's wife
look i don't know um the specifics
around that and what i can tell you is
we want to see the judge made privacy
law curtail we think free speech in this
country is something which should have a
higher pecking order for example the
article 8 right privacy we also want to
protect journalistic sources and i think
frankly kay you know as a journalist and
a lot of people have talked about this
there's been a feeling whether it's
political correctness whether you call
it woke whatever the language is that
the scope for rambunctious but
legitimate debates be narrowed i think
our bill of rights will strengthen the
space for those debates okay the chair
of the common standards committee chris
bryant says it's manifestly corrupt so
appoint your lover as a special adviser
what would you say to him
i don't think that's what's happened i
think that's particularly responsible
language and frankly these attacks on
cary i think are deeply unsavory it
didn't happen because it would have been
corrupt if it had happened well look the
the the allegations that have been made
and i've read some of the newspaper
reportings has been
roundly uh uh responded to as flawed um
those are matters for number 10 for
carrie to answer but but frankly i think
what you're seeing is a political attack
on cary as a means to get uh the prime
minister and i think that's out of order
well lord knight says the situation is
right for investigation
well look um i as i say i don't know the
individual circumstances uh the prime
minister
views don't you of course i do but i'm
just saying i think that um they've been
very clear number ten has been very
clear that these uh claims are flawed so
there's a sort of feeding frenzy on
everything or anything that is even
thrown out there as a as a claim against
the prime minister or in this case his
wife and i think that's wrong okay but
why not just have the investigation and
it's all cleared up well
who's calling i mean lord uh lord gate
is no longer in that position there's
going to be some respected views yeah of
course i do that doesn't mean that um
there's lots of people who's used our
respect but ultimately uh the number ten
have been very clear on this um and as i
said i think it's a partisan attack and
i think it's very it's very unfortunate
it's it that carries being used to
attack the prime minister that's not on
okay we're almost out of time um how did
it fit for you earlier on in the week
for size and being prime minister again
even for a short time do you know what i
i don't um get uh particularly overall
by any of that i'm there to do a job to
support the prime minister uh when he
needs me and uh you know we've got a
great cabinet everyone knows what
they're doing and i i'm uh really happy
to hold the reigns if necessary sounds
like a leadership pitch to me no not at
all i mean i've said before i won't
stand again
well i i actually remember um michael
goes saying that to me
and then he stood again yeah i'm not
quite uh in the same position as michael
but look i can only tell you what i've
uh what i've said before okay we won't
have to play this to you in a year's
time no when you're standing no no no
because the prime minister will be
poised to win the next lecture
justin at the end there it's always
great to see you thanks so much for
joining us thank you